hello there guys and welcome to another
commentary video
so we have just gotten a new trailer for
season two of
mandalorian um i would say it's more of
a teaser but they have shown some new
footage which we will do a little
breakdown of
so without further ado let's get into
the video
so it starts off with some new republic
x-wings chase into razor crest
which we have seen in previous trailers
and tv spots
but we weren't sure if amanda was
working with them or not
but it looks like they're actually
chasing mando because they said razor
crest
stand down so obviously they're after
him for some reason
maybe he's violated something he's in
territory that he's not meant to be in
so yeah let's continue
okay so we've got some new shots here of
an ice planet which i actually think
this planet is ulum which we have seen
in fallen order in the clone wars tv
show
um it just looks so much like the planet
and amanda is searching for a sorcerer
for
the jedi it kind of makes sense that
he's coming to a planet like ulum
because you know this planet has a
strong connection to the force
it's where the jedi come to um get their
kyber crystals
so possibly he's searching for ahsoka
here but more on that later in the video
i'm here on business i need your help
i've been quested to bring this one back
to its kind
so mando is back with the crew he's
teaming up again with grief kaga
and kara doon they are currently on
nararo here we've got a couple new shots
here
and i love how mando is just carrying
baby yoda in his hand
there amanda says here that he's been
quested to bring this one back to its
kind
obviously referring to baby yoda or
formerly known as the child
so um you know this leads me to believe
that a large portion of the season will
be about
mando trying to deliver baby yoda back
to its home world
or wherever they are located so it's
quite possible we'll actually see yoda's
home world after all this time
his species may get a name reveal or it
could be kept a mystery um
if mando is successful with this mission
we'll most likely get a name reveal for
baby yoda and if he is successful his
mission
do you think baby yoda will be given
back or will amanda somehow manage to
keep him
possibly there's none left of his kind
so
when he gets to their homeworld it's
possible there could be no one left but
baby yoda
i don't know but tell me what you think
anyway let's continue
so we've got a quick shot heat of
testimony and at the start of the frame
we actually
see a band for skeleton here and then we
see mando on a speeder bike
which in previous trailers we also saw
him on a speeder bike as well on
tatooine
if i can locate other mandalorians they
can guide me
okay so we've got some new footage of
the ice planet which i think is ulum
and mando says if i can locate other
mandalorians they could guide me
so i actually think you will find
another mandalorian that can help him
and i think that meant lauren is sabine
because in the first trailer when armor
is telling mandalorian to um
look for the jedi we cut to a person
that is rumored to be
um sabine so let's say that is to bend
so mandalorian is
looking for mandalorian which sabine is
a mandalorian and he's looking for
guidance
um who does sabine though ahsokatano so
it's possible sabine will help demand
lauren
find a circa tyleno which you could
possibly be on ulum or
she told mando to go to ulum for a
certain reason that we don't know yet so
i don't that's what i think i think
mando's been instructed to come to this
planet for some reason
and it'll help him on his quest to find
baby yoda's homeland
so that's how i think ahsoka will come
into this season sabine
will lead amanda to her the next shot we
have
mando repairing his ship which looks
like has taken a fair bit of damage
this is nothing new to man though his
his ship always finds itself in trouble
somehow um it looks like this damage was
possibly caused by the crash he had
in the start of the trailer this is no
place for a child
wherever i go he goes
so we have pretty much seen this scene
from previous trailers but there are a
couple new shots
towards the end here it looks like mando
is about to have some action
and it looks like he's about to pull his
blaster out
so in the next couple shots we have a
troop transport that rides off
which looks like to be an imperial
outpost of some kind
or maybe a different outpost which i
think this planet is actually narraro
because we can see some lava underground
and it has the same rocky
environment that we have seen previously
so in this troop transport we see
grief cara dune and a methyl which i
spoke about in my earlier video
and i do believe this guy is the same
one from season one
anyway so then the troop transport
crushes the scout troop on a speeder
bike
and then we have to squad back together
looks like they're infiltrated in some
base of some kind it could be that
outpost we spoke about previously or it
could be a star destroyer but he does
have his jet pack on here and in some
previous scenes
or previous trailers we saw amanda using
his jet pack on the same rocky
environment which i think is navarro so
it's kind of safe to assume that this is
the same scene and the same sequence
and you know i guess the jet pack
wouldn't be too handy in a star
destroyer anyway and then we cut to
a shot of grief karga looking like he's
in the troop transport here again and
you can see just outside the window it
looks like it's the same rocking
environment
so it's also safe to assume this is
another continuation of the troop
transport clip
here we go
and then we have an extended shot of
mando using this jet pack and it's
looking quite sweet
anyway that's about it for this little
breakdown nothing too in-depth
i thought i'll just um do a little
breakdown for you guys i was hoping to
see a socatano or maybe a little tease
about her
appearance but overall this trailer um
plays it pretty safe
they don't really showcase anything too
much um it's quite spoiler free
most of the stuff we have seen are from
previous trailers that we have seen
so i'm guessing most of this stuff will
be from the first few episodes
and overall we haven't seen too much
footage of this season which
i guess is a good thing because i mean
this will be in for a lot of surprises
hopefully
but anyway guys what do you think of
this trailer do you wish they'd shown
more
or are you happy that they played it
safe and didn't show too much also tell
me in the comment section below if you
want more breakdowns like this or
possibly more in-depth ones
or something else and with that out of
the way please like subscribe and i'll
catch you guys
in the next video
[Music]
so
[Music]
you